j'ai ruiné ce gorille la pohdh c'est une
horreur il ya du sable dedans et je vais
essayer de faire un petit coup d'oeil sa
mère juste pour vous montrez vous en dit
pas si vous entendez mais on sent le
sable alors je vais pas en racheter un
neuf pour autant je vais juste ici le
nettoyer correctement et d'en sortir
quelque chose de bien tessi père
françois
[Musique]
et salue les gens derrière l'écran c'est
françois pour la chaîne explique mme
encore je suis ravie comme à chaque fois
2 vous retrouver pour une nouvelle vidéo
sur un angle un petit peu différent là
j'ai eu envie de vous montrer un petit
peu le studio brut dans son jus éclairé
d'accord mais pas mis en scène par ce
que je voulais évoquer un petit peu tout
ce matériel que j'ai ici parler avec
vous de ce dont je me sers régulièrement
est ce qu'il ya des choses dont je me
sers pas comment j'utilise un petit peu
cet espace et le matériel qui a deux
dents bref voilà vous parler un petit
peu de tout ça parce que je me dis ça
peut vous intéresser ça peut aussi vous
inspirer pour votre fonctionnement à
vous et puis on répondra à cette
question voilà est-ce que tout ça c'est
vraiment nécessaire
on y va on va commencer par la partie la
plus importante c'est à dire de nettoyer
ce capteur qui est dégueulasse pour
octobre et si j'ai un petit meuble avec
des petites étiquettes parce qu'il ya
trop de de tirua et on va commencer par
nettoyer ce capteur qui est
particulièrement des gueux voilà j'avais
pas vu mais avec le reflet sait pas ou
alors je disais donc la première chose
qu'on va aller voir c'est le set up de
caméras pour filmer alors ici on peut
voir donc le set 6 2 avec 1 24 mm f/1 8g
focale fixe parce que le 24 mm au final
c'est ce que je préfère utiliser l'atome
aussi si qui me sert alors pour youtube
uniquement de retour un trépied ici
alors c'est peut-être être un petit peu
son mais ça va se voir un trépied qu'une
pure copie de manfrotto qui marche très
très bien c'est un gros trépied je
l'aimé bien parce que du coup ce set
applied fx il bouge pas et ben du coup
ça me permet d'avoir quelque chose qui
risquent pas de tomber de tourner de
bouger quand j'ai fait mon cadrage y
bouge plus le tout est tenu par une
demie cage small rich qui me permet de
fixer tous les accessoires que je veux y
a pas de prise de son directement sur le
boîtier je fais une prise de son qui est
séparé mais ça on en a parlé un petit
peu après alors vous allez me dire mais
pourquoi du coup tu fais pas des prises
en gros réseau comme tu nous as dit et
tout sur les vidéos ici il ya tout
simplement parce que j'ai un contrôle
total sur la lumière donc en fait
l'enregistrement avec le set 6 2 en
interne même si c'est du 4 2 0
guide ça marche nickel surtout pour
youtube si je faisais mes vidéos youtube
en progrès 0 j'aurais des quantités
astronomiques de roche qu'il faudrait
stocker et ça serait assez compliqué là
pour le coup en interne avec ses
lumières dont on va parler un petit peu
plus tard ben j'ai aucun problème là
dessus et ça marche très très bien je
suis en sorte d'avoir une prise hyper
propres pour avoir le moins de choses à
retoucher possible maintenant on va
s'attaquer un petit peu au bureau 1 je
vais vous montrer le bureau de l'espace
le bureau de la mort un truc de fou
alors ce bureau ici que j'ai là voilà
tout pouvait voir ici avec ma tasse de
café dessus mon ordi mon micro tout ça
est bien ce bureau de tenez vous bien
c'est juste une planche
voilà avec deux très tôt pourquoi j'ai
opté pour sa bien tout simplement parce
que ça me permet de le déplacer
si je dois ajouter des produits par
exemple je peux mettre une like it up
light par dessus je peux le déplacer
mettre dans un coin
si j'avais besoin de l'espace j'enlève
la planche j'enlève le très tôt je les
pose contre un mur et j'ai beaucoup plus
d'espacé sur tout ça ce module
facilement parce que j'ai besoin de
pouvoir changer la disposition
si j'ai besoin puisque ce bureau ne sert
pas que à youtube bien évidemment ah oui
et puis ici c'est légèrement insonorisé
pour casser un petit peu le rebond en
fait du son même si c'est pas parfait ça
aurait nécessité d'avoir des choses au
plafond et où j'ai essayé mais c'était
un petit peu galère ça viendra ou pas
mais pour l'instant ça reste à mon sens
assez sympa dans tout ce qui est light
je voulais garde pour la fin parce que
c'est le plus gros morceau et c'est ce
sur quoi je travaille le plus en fait
pour avoir mon image
là je vais vous montrer en termes
d'accessoires pratiques ce que j'ai
toujours à portée de main et ce qui me
permet de jamais être gênée on va dire
parce qu il va me manquer un petit truc
voilà ça c'est super important d'avoir
toutes ces petites choses la up
allez donc je vous parlais au début de
ce petit meuble ici donc là dans le
premier tiroir j'ai des batteries
j'ai tout un tas de câbles ça c'est
quand même vachement important d'avoir
des câbles du hdmi de l'usb ici j'ai
toute ma partie sont donc j'ai un
enregistreur généreuse wireless go ici
j'ai un casque et d'autres choses que je
stocke quand je les utilise pas une
partie nettoyage ici on a tout un tas de
trucs qui se vissent notamment pour les
les accessoires small rigal orge et des
plateaux roger des poignets j'ai des
dramas gic-g des pinces j'ai déclenché
un bref j'ai vraiment énormément de
choses là dedans
l'idée c'est que je puisse accrocher
tout un tas de trucs et en parlant d'
accrocher
alors vous allez pouvoir peut-être le
voir ici je vais vous montrer là j'ai
une méga ici on la voit je sais pas
là j'ai mes gamins ce qui me permet de
fixer cette light ici à l'étagère qui
est là donc ça s'appelle des superclubs
et c'est hyper pratique j'en ai un
deuxième encore plus pratique avec autre
chose complet juste ici tout ce que je
vous mets ici tout ce dont je joue pas
c'est en lien dans la description si
c'est des choses qui vous intéresse
c'est des liens affiliés amazon bien sûr
mais voilà tout est en lien dans la
description
voilà ici on a ce truc là qui est juste
génial ça c'est manfrotto qui fait ça
c'est ce qu'ils appellent un auto paul
c'est à dire que c'est une espèce
d'énorme bar qui vient tenir en fait par
pression en haut et en bas et qui
m'évite d'avoir trop de pertes au sol
ici et de pouvoir stocker des trucs
comme cet écran qui ne marchent plus par
exemple voilà tout simplement
ensuite la lite elle est fixée de la
même façon avec un super temple le même
ce que ce qu'il ya de l'autre côté hyper
costaud j'avais vu ça tient direct à les
guerres la lite on va en parler un petit
peu après mais ça c'est juste génial par
exemple du coup nouveaux accessoires je
suis quand même assez bien là dès que
j'ai besoin d'un câble dès que j'ai
besoin d'une pince dès que j'ai besoin
d'un bras magique
j'ai tout sous la main et ça c'est quand
même assez pratique la danse et case je
range le bordel voilà c'est dit c'est
fait c'est juste voilà du rangement
pratique rien de très intéressantes
dedans si c'est l'état gère avec les
objectifs et les boîtiers quand on s'en
sert pas mais ça c'est une autre paire
de manches
alors et puisqu'on parle des objectifs
et des boîtiers ici nous avons le
cette recette de marie avec le 70 200 f
2,8 qui est une pure tuerie
voilà ce que ce que marie a bien entendu
son boîtier à elle est comme elle fait
plus de photos on est parti sur le z 7,2
pour eve ensuite à seynod optiques nikon
donc on a ici le 50 mm f/1 8 le 35 mm
f/1 8 que j'adore le 24 70 f 2,8 qui est
vraiment très très bien ici sur sur cet
objectif ici sur lausanne 6 2 que j'ai
dans les mains c'est le 14 24
grand-angle vraiment très très cool
aussi
ici j'ai quelques optique en monture
canon donc une famille yang 16 mm et la
cazine 24 mm pour comme monture canon
raid komodo un qui va bientôt arriver
j'espère qu'ils manquent l'hélios que
j'ai pas ici mais que j'ai testé sur la
chaîne qui est vachement bien là on a
quelques figurines et le lanoye le 24 mm
problème ce que là pour le coup
j'utilise assez peu un filtre end et le
ciné blum de mount du filetage et on est
pas mal déjà la nive au niveau optique
on a déjà bien le 24 mm qui est monté
sur la came pour youtube ici est on est
on est on est quand même sacrément bien
équipée niveau optique a ensuite bien
sûr je viens de vous le dire mais tout
un tas là ici de trépied et autres pieds
et le slider peu tout ce qui est pro doc
chuck un pied de micro ici ça sert
toujours le petit oui bill est ce qui va
bien même si je suis pas hyper fan des
guiboles celui-là il est très très bien
il porte close et 6 et ça rende bas
hyper bien c'est vraiment cool donc je
les aime beaucoup
alors maintenant on va parler de ce qui
est le plus important à mon avis ici
dans ce set up c'est la lumière ce qui
me permet de ne pas trop avoir à m'en
faire en termes de captation avec le
matos que je vais utiliser dans ses
plats c'est ici forcément quand je me
déplace ici c'est un petit peu le bordel
puisque ben les lumières sont fixes mais
je vais vous expliquer un petit peu
comment j'ai clair tout ça alors
la ici on a donc là qu'il ait qui est
une api tueur 120 des marques 2 avec le
grand dôme qui va avec est fixé sur
l'auto paul que je vous ai montré tout à
l'heure ça c'est ma qu'il ait que j'aime
beaucoup qui est vraiment très très bien
le seul truc que je trouve un petit peu
dommage avec ce qu'il ait c'est que il
ya des nouveaux trucs qui sont sorties
qui sont vachement moins cher je trouve
que c'est ta culture elle est très cher
pour ce que c'est que aujourd'hui chez
go dogs ou même chez a picture ils ont
sorti des choses un petit peu plus
abordable dans les 300 euros qui font
vraiment bien le taf bon n'empêche que
ça c'est résistance est costaud ça
devrait durer hyper longtemps sacema
qu'il ait que je place ici aux trois
quarts sur mon visage quand je suis
assis au bureau l'a ensuite j'ai cette
light qui est une falco niles et pliable
et qui ici fixé avec du velcro sur le
sur le mur celle ci elle me sert de fil
light c'est à dire qu'elle va venir
combler un petit peu sur le côté le
manque de lumière puisque j'ai ma qu'il
ait aux trois quarts sur l'autre côté et
j'ai clair en trois points avec cette
dernière ici light qui est une api
turquie et les premières à culture que
j'ai acheté les amarres anne qui sont
des light l'aide très peu cher est bon
qu'ils sont bien ils sont sympas c'est
pas fou fou mais ça fait largement le
taf et surtout en battle est grosso modo
j'ai gardé tout mais light en fait j'ai
jamais revendu de light je les garde et
j'ai construit un petit peu le setup
d'éclairage comme ça après hop on va
activer la boue ensuite j'ai mes petites
light philips que tout le monde a mais
qui sont plus pour de la déco donc ici
j'ai du fil à manger la mobile j'ai
celle ci qui est ici là aussi alors
c'est pas des like pour éclairer
contrairement aux premières c'est
vraiment de la déco purement et
simplement
j'avais déjà c'est light avant pour la
déco et je les ai réutilisés dans ce
studio pour ramener un petit un petit
peu de couleurs un petit truc un peu un
peu sympa après j'ai ces deux là ces
données on vous m'avez beaucoup beaucoup
demandé ce que c'était ce sont des light
de shenzhen light c'est l'épave au tube
60 je crois parce qu'ils font 60 cm
c'est live elles ont l'air vachement
accessoires elles ont l'air vachement
juste déco et en fait non je m'en sert
énormément sur mes tournages parce
qu'elles sont sur batterie on peut les
mettre en couleurs on peut les mettre
aussi en blanc et je lui en suis déjà
servi de lumière principal sur certains
tournages que j'ai déjà fait c'est
vraiment vraiment d'elite que j'aime
beaucoup l'autonomie je les ai jamais
poussé à bout mais ça doit durer à peu
près une heure c'est quand même assez
sympa et ça permet de dépanner vraiment
comment d'ailleurs en parlant de
dépannage ici j'ai des petites led
d'appoint celle ci celle ci celle ci
alors les marques c'est du coup c'est
sous nouvelle ça c'est des trucs comme
envoyer c'est pas un truc que j'ai
acheté j'aime bien parce qu'elles sont
aimantés celle ci c'est un peu le même
principe que les pavots tubes mais en
version vain une 35 à 30 centimètres ça
doit faire ça et celles ci elles sont
très pratiques pour déboucher une ombre
à droite à gauche ou se servir de petits
effets qui sont intégrés qui sont pas
mal et niveau lite on a fait à peu près
le tour alors les lumières principal
elles ont toutes un diffuseur bien sûr
parce que sinon ça serait trop dur et je
préfère comme ça c'est je trouve ça
beaucoup plus doux beaucoup plus
agréable j'utilise plus les nids
d'abeilles que j'avais qui étaient
fournis parce que finalement comme ça je
trouve ça pas mal mais de temps en temps
ça m'arrive d'avoir envie de changer du
coup je place les abeilles pour
rediriger un petit peu plus la lumière
maintenant qu'on a fait le tour de tout
ça on va aller se poser sur le set-up
habituel on va rebrancher un petit peu
tout et on va enregistrer avec tout ça
ni bien comme il faut pour avoir un beau
face cannes et on va parler un petit peu
du fait que bien sûr que tout ça c'est
totalement overkill totalement
surdimensionné pour youtube
bien sûr ah oui et j'ai oublié niveau
micro ici c'est un line 6 que j'utilise
et que j'enregistre en parallèle sur mon
ordi en séparer pour après synchronisée
pour avoir le meilleur audio possible
celui ci c'est un road vidéo mike pro
plus pareil lien description il est très
bien pour de l'extérieur pour du
reportage ça capte bien l'ambiance c'est
pas un micro voix off comme celui-là
mais très très bonne qualité j'aime
beaucoup je vous mets les références
description alors oui ce que je vous
disais tout ça bien sûr que c'est
totalement surdimensionné pour faire du
youtube vous n'avez pas besoin d'avoir
tout ça c'est quel degré d' hypocrisie
ce que je vous dis puisque moi j'ai tout
ça et je vous dis que vous en avez pas
besoin bien une raison simple au fait
que j'ai tout ce matos l'a déjà jeu-là
cumule depuis un petit moment ce
matériel j'ai revendu plein de choses
quand j'ai changé notamment de boîtiers
et tout ça mais j'accumule pas mal de
matos le truc c'est que tout ce matériel
là il est stocké ici mais en fait je me
sers d'absolument tout ce qui se trouve
dans cette pièce sauf le lanoye macro
que j'utilise très peu voilà je les ai
achetés sur un craquage et je n'aurais
peut-être pas dû parce que j'ai pas
forcément la clientèle pour ça mais tous
âges eux l'utilisent pour mes prod parce
que vous le savez un suivi des as tu
sais mon métier donc toutes celles ait
tous ces objets tous ces câbles toutes
ces batteries tout ça en fait ça me sert
au quotidien pour une production la
future pour des interviews ses caviars
c'est juste génial la falcon a expliqué
ici pour des choses où j'ai besoin
d'être léger pour refaire un petit peu
aussi d'interviews éclairé débouchés des
ombres parce que l'endroit où je me
situe niveau lumière c'est pas fou c'est
juste parfait ça pèse rien c'est hyper
facile à transporter on peut le mettre
sur un trépied très léger c'est génial
les deux boîtiers sur un mariage bat
pour moi c'est indispensable d'avoir un
boîtier de secours et les optiques les
zooms c'est surtout mari qui les
utilisent pareil pour faire ces
magnifiques photos que je vous invite à
aller voir sur notre instinct qui
s'affiche un petit peu ici c'est
toujours cool bref les sacs les trépieds
la discrète tout ça en fait j'en ai un
besoin absolu je manque de rien ça c'est
génial mais il n'y a rien dans cette
pièce hormis encore une fois peut-être
un objet que j'utilise pas dans mon
boulot alors vous de votre côté de quoi
est-ce que vous avez besoin
j'ai envie de dire une caméra un micro
surtout un peu d'éclairage pas besoin
d'en avoir forcément autant je me suis
longtemps éclairé avec une seule light
bien placé un peu moins trois quarts un
peu plus face éventuellement une petite
led de dépannage comme j'ai ici pour la
backelite mais si vous avez une chaîne
youtube ya moyen de faire des choses
très très bien sans pour autant dépenser
des milliers d'euros et à voir tout ce
truc là qui est pas forcément utile pour
une chaîne youtube
il pose kawa sachant bien sûr que le
plus important c'est votre caméra votre
histoire votre cadrage on est bien
d'accord mais n'empêche qu'il ya des
éléments de matériels qui permettent
d'être vachement plus serein quand on
tourne quelque chose est la dernière
chose qui se situe ici enfin plutôt en
dessous de la vidéo c'est le pouce en
l'air que vous pouvez bien entendu blast
et si vous avez aimé cette vidéo pouvez
aussi vous abonner regarder d'autres
vidéos laisser un commentaire me dire ce
que vous avez pensé un petit peu de
cette façon différente de vous présenter
le studio un petit peu plus roots un
petit peu plus a larache et puis moi je
vous dis les amis rester curieux et à
très bientôt pour une prochaine vidéo